[Music]  occasionally it probably has everybody  at work but this happens here to our  staff members bring kids to work and  they bring them in and the kids are  always very cute and I love meeting the  children of the staff so I thought it  might be fun to ask staff members kids  what their parents think about working  for me and so yeah it's really adorable  it's a little piece we've shot it's  called staffers kids say the darndest  things does your mom like working for  coatings no she said that he smells like  rotten cabbage my dad says Coleman  spends most of his money on lipstick and  guns I told my mom if she didn't take  the cash under the table he would have  her deported one time my dad was live  for work and Conan called him one of  God's greatest mistakes what if your mom  say about Conan my mom said one time  Conan cornered her in the stairwell then  he said give me some of that sweet sweet  honey baby now she cries a lot  you  you